shocking shocking new NBC news/wall
Street Journal poll has Donald Trump 14
points behind Hillary Clinton 11 points
behind if you include Gary Johnson and
Jill Stein let's take a look at a number
of recent polls according to real clear
politics and the Real Clear Politics
average as you can see Hillary Clinton
leading by an average of six point five
percentage points and up 14 in a recent
NBC news/wall Street Journal poll and as
you look at that graph you see that over
the last uh just the first 10 or so days
of October Donald Trump's polling
numbers falling off of a cliff and
Hillary Clinton steadily climbing now
remember sometimes people see Oh
Hillary's winning by an average of 6.5
and you've got a margin of error for a
four or five so maybe Hillary Clinton's
basically tied or winning by two that's
possible but as Nate Silver told us +
6.5 with a margin of error of five means
that Hillary Clinton is just as likely
to be winning by 11.5 which would be
needless to say a historic defeat for
Donald Trump if that were to hold how
has the 538 election forecast changed
over recent days well it continues to
increase for Hillary Clinton as of this
morning Hillary Clinton currently with
an eighty-four percent chance of being
the next president of the United States
Donald Trump a sixteen percent chance
not the best odds for Donald Trump at
this time this does not even include
polling following the second
presidential debate which was of course
an embarrassing and classless disaster
for Donald Trump we will have those
numbers probably by the end of this week